[Music]
hello my name is Emilio Sante I'm sat
here with Samuel leaves and the reason
why I believe he has such a big property
portfolio is because he has such a big
personal brand so in this episode we're
gonna be talking how he did that and
also how you can do it too
so what's excited to you this week this
week probably going to see Martin Lewis
with you mmm that was kind of cool
though yeah what's cool I wanted to go
in secret but we totally got exposed yes
I didn't tell you but this morning one
of the ladies from one of the other
offices showed me a picture of me
because you know we had yours on the
Facebook group this is really important
spotted you yeah she spied me yeah that
is so random crazy
so you're fat you're only came to fame
and being on the podcast that's great
funny I kind of wanted to go in secret a
little bit because the reason I want I
wanted to see Mike you know I actually
don't really agree with I don't agree
with it but Martin Lewis obsesses over
how to save money and I'd love to bring
him on my youtube show see if anyone's
listening to this and knows Martin Lewis
has connections connect me with him I
think he's a really nice guy I think he
says a lot of really good stuff but
obsessing over how to save the pennies
you're gonna miss the pounds but the
crazy thing is he's a very wealthy guy
and I just think surely surely he's
actually not that bothered about how to
say five pounds off a mobile phone bill
bra is his brand it is his brand his
brand is how to save money and how to
count the pinch the pennies and all that
stuff I'm just not into that so I just
thought if I go see him in person seem
live go on his show is it actually gonna
enlighten me
am I gonna because you don't want to
hang out of people that always agree
with you yeah you want to hang out
people that sometimes don't agree with
you so when in secret got exposed saw
myself all over line even you got expose
ya know yeah so it was cool it was
really interesting to see like a TV soap
cuz obviously we do YouTube and I was
interested see
they do TV it seemed very scripted yeah
and it was initially cause it was
obviously alive as well so that was
gonna interest in serious kind of like
it was lies but not live yeah because
yeah he's awesome but he's very
different
I much prefer the freedom that you have
on YouTube yeah than TV people probably
think that your YouTube videos are
sometimes scheduled and like scripted
but what you are gonna say to me yeah
remember someone said when you
interviewed me oh I bet you were three
questions I'm like even Emilia doesn't
know the questions beforehand let alone
me you know and they ask me anything
stuff he's really ask me anything yeah
just ask me anything challenges people
can literally even in the crash courses
I'll say hey he wants to ask me because
people stand up ask me questions yeah
it's just completely yeah where is that
Q&A like they think they had people
asking questions but they were like
they'd already chose them and that kind
of thing so yeah TVs harder I guess
because it wants us out there TV how
many how many celebrities have we
interviewed yeah I'm not knocking the
people man not at all but they're always
always always you need to give you
questions up front and they go over the
questions and then they'll can you don't
ask about this you know ask about this
and although you asking questions it's
kind of like very much the questions
it's just not free and maybe maybe I'll
do that maybe maybe someday I'll do that
but right now I'm a diva right now I
just have the realness have just been
able to just talk about anything give my
opinion not not worry about being too PC
and and just speak but you've even got
your own YouTube channel yes I have I
need to get so a star in from 2020
properly once a week I'm gonna be
posting on my you to believe it but the
thing is everybody can be an influencer
I know this is something that you
believe really passionately cuz you're
even telling all of the guys in the
office everybody has a brand yeah
comfortable that so I just strongly
believe in personal branding and I feel
like it's one of those things I preach
but I don't do mmm you do
because you're also here with me right
now that's true I just feel like the
extent of what I believe in it yeah I
don't think I want to be a case study
for what I believe yes and I believe
everyone can have influence everyone has
a brand everyone can almost make
themselves a celebrity yeah so that's
what I'm gonna be doing in 2020 is
basically proven that good yeah good
yeah I'm super excited I'm so I'm so
supportive of you in that anyone in that
I think and something you said really
interesting to me because I know you're
part of you're actually part of the team
you've got a career here with us but you
said the you'd rather have a personal
brand yeah than money in the bank yeah
and a personal brand is more power for
the money in the bank
yeah which is kind of cool yeah I'm so
true what did you mean by that so I just
think for example when you do your FF
challenges yeah one of the things you
were saying is I like for example you
made up Lucas Ruby because if you walk
into an estate agents you know that
because you're some real leads I'll
probably know you there might be nicer
to you might help you and yeah it's just
like almost like an unfair advantage but
it's not unfair because you've worked to
build yours as any other property
investor they could build their personal
brand so they have the same privileges
that when you walk in people be like are
maybe take you a bit more seriously
maybe help you out a little bit so yeah
I just think I just think going into a
room and people already know in who you
are and already having some sort of
level of maybe respect for you or
trusting you if you fell in deals and
stuff it's just such an amazing thing
and it just means that you know people
already know what you do is all you have
to go around network in the room saying
I have Amelia I do this people already
know who you are so if they've got any
kind of business proposals or they want
to connect they can just come to you
straight away you know it's crazy about
Lucas Roubaix yep Lucas Ruby built his
own brand that way honestly to the point
where because because ruby was
networking I don't even think I've told
you that I think I thought anyone there
but Lucas tribulus networking so Lucas
Ruby for anyone that's listening who's
thinking who the heck is Ruby when I
started again from scratch no money in
the bank
nothing and a new identity so I couldn't
even leave which off of my brand I gave
myself the name Lukas Ruby with a wig
and glasses and stuff like that but but
as the week went on because I was
networking this Lukas Roubaix and I was
talking to me boss advising people and I
was saying hey I'm Lukas appoint a
little avoid the wick people were like
saying Oh Lukas they were messaging me
you know there are many events because I
network like hardcore Oh
Lukas have you got any deals only
because there was a couple of other deal
sources but we've resonated have you
best Lucas and I had Lucas on his own
Facebook page people are adding Lucas
and and by the end of the week I thought
of I kind of felt bad that I had to let
go of the Lucas Ruby brand because Lucas
Ruby literally had his own little
following and I just thought
Samuel leads has got it has got his own
I say here's I speaking I speak like
that because Sammy's is two things
though Samuel leads the person which is
me and then the Samuel leads the brand
yep and as it happens some you leave the
person and Samuel is the brand are very
similar much of the same person
sometimes that's not the case
yeah sometimes you've got the brand and
the person and they're very different
but no one really knows what some
celebrities are like in real life
yeah they know the brand you know so
when people meet me in real life they're
like oh man you quite actually the same
as the brand but I don't remember I was
going with this I know what I was gonna
say I was saying if I was starting over
again from scratch literally with a new
identity yeah let's say let's say
someone wiped or if I went to another
country mm-hm okay where no one knew who
I was I would so build the Samuel he's
grown back or the job how would you go
about that
I would document and vlog everything I'm
doing okay so like every time I'm doing
it and it doesn't even have to be like
amazing look at people like Patricia
bright for instance yeah who's amazing
but she wasn't document in her life and
showing her met herself making millions
and millions of pounds and growing a
massive company
I mean she's did some great stuff but
she was just documenting her life
some people just document their family
that their selves as a mom
they just dock you in their life but if
it's interesting and if it's valuable
then people will start was too hot
following yeah
so you would vlog so if you have to
start your personal brand again tomorrow
in another country you would start
vlogging is there anything else you
would do blogging is a form of telling
people what you're doing but I would
just tell the world what I'm doing in
every possible which were could say
false start again in Australia I'd just
be like Samuel Leeds starts again in
Australia
Samuel Leeds views his first house in
Australia somebody's puts forward that
his first offer in Australia everything
would be a story
everything will be documented when I
bought my first house and Leeds boys his
first ours sunny leaves us to kick out
his first tenant second house third
house 4050 now Samuel is just
financially free and then I'd be going
to the newspapers with the stories I'd
be going to the I'll be trying to make
something newsworthy trying to make
things interesting resonating with
people putting it out there because I
know that in business people think you
need a lot of money you do not need a
lot of money in business and something
you make it sound too easy you make it
something with your true listen man I
don't make it sound easy it's just on
the businessperson and I know that in
order to make money what money comes
from people and the thing you need is
you need people to know that you exist
yeah if people know that you exist then
you can make money from up from a
service or a product or a joint venture
agreement because people know you people
trust you you have a reputation you can
have a million pounds in the bank but if
you have it but no one knows who you are
if you haven't got the there's the three
things that you need to do to make money
you need knowledge you need network
people and you need money
my name is the least important because
you can get money from people when
people know who you are because your
network yeah and I think it's a lot
easier than people think is yeah to
build to build some sort of following or
some sort or resonating with some group
of people I don't think it's that hard
for example like when I started doing
YouTube videos about a year ago I didn't
really have a goal in mind for me it was
more just like I wanted to kind of feel
the fear and do it anyway
and starting posting content and I did a
likely cause it leads University at the
University of Leeds and I did a video on
my freshers week and I also did one on
my study abroad year I think they got
like a few thousand views
and I got a message officer Study Abroad
department at leas they wanted me to do
it like a talk to like 500 people and
all these different things so actually
it's even though I know people will be
like all YouTube's aTTRA is this
saturated but I think when you go in
eating going down different avenues I
don't think it's as hard as people think
it is I think something saturated I mean
goodness me
the world is saturated with seven
billion people which means there's more
people trying to do it there's also more
eyeballs waiting for you to do to watch
yeah and the best hand start is 20 years
ago and the second-best now yeah that's
right yeah the best time to plant a tree
is twenty years ago the second best is
today yeah I just I find it so
interesting as well because I was
listening to on my way back from
Manchester at the weekend I was on
Instagram and I don't know I've talked
to you about him before but Steven
Bartlett who is the head of social chain
if no-one knows him and he was doing an
Instagram live with Umar Kimani if I'm
saying it right who is the owner of
pretty little thing I don't know whether
you know about pretty little things
clothing and he's basically just taken
the world by storm in terms of his brand
yeah and they were actually saying like
the difference between a business and a
brand and Umar was saying a lot of
businesses think that their brands
weren't actually they're just a business
yeah which I found that was super
interesting because I feel like the
Samuel Leeds business or will be the
freedom formula that was - yeah yeah
like Steven was saying that a lot of his
business comes through his personal
brand and not actually his business I
think that's kind of like the same with
you like you kind of built your brand
and that's kind of where everything's
coming from like the whole business is
built off your personal brand it is now
but I only realized about personal
branding about four years ago in Justice
so well to some extent I probably knew
about okay when I started building my
business I would network yeah I had a
CRM system I would get business cards
put them on my CRM system drop emails
out and stuff like that and I knew that
you have to get people in front of you I
think what I didn't know is the power of
online branding so in in in the property
kind of tight-knit circles and community
people knew others it's like young guy
who's do
really wedding property he's I was even
I was just putting myself out I was
doing I was doing crazy stuff like I was
renting rooms out for free because that
gets that gets attention
he's many rooms out for free if you're a
landlord he's just managing your
properties are free was that on em was
that something you would document it or
just me document it okay I didn't
realize at the time I didn't have anyone
to tell me that I needed to but just a
fact Wells doing it uh-huh people were
talking about it like 50 years ago there
was no door even last there was no
internet was there so could could you
still have a personal brand without the
internet not in the way we know it today
where do you think you would be now
without YouTube I think I would be way
less known but you can of course you can
have a personal brand about the internet
because having a personal brand is
basically just being well-known or being
famous people were famous long before
the Internet yeah but personal brand is
anything a personal brand is just a
person I guess a brand so a brand so
personal brand to me is I think Jeff
maybe and it's a person that quoted it
was like a personal brand is what people
say about you and you're not in the room
so the way people think about you yeah
so everyone has one yeah so everyone has
one but everybody was wondering I guess
and it's like actively working on it
like some people will just be like I
don't know her branded off brand so they
won't work on it but I think that's kind
of like a naive way to think about it
like as soon as you own the fact that
you have a personal brand it means you
can start working to almost make your
personal brand what you want it yeah and
I think it's nothing about because I
guess some people would think oh maybe
you know see that as maybe like a fake
thing like all your manipulating kind of
who you are but it's more just like
putting your best foot forward and being
like these are the best things about me
and this is what I want to be known for
rather than and they're not only talking
about that but becoming that yeah so
saying who do I want to be yeah and then
becoming that and it's the same as
everyone's got a personal about
everybody I believe everybody's a leader
yeah everybody's a leader of unless you
just literally don't know anybody in
your isolated in your house on your own
but if you've got kids you're a leader
yeah you know everybody's a leader but
it's just a case of acknowledging that
and
and being aware of it and saying
actually everything I do has a
consequence sometimes good sometimes bad
and I need to really think about my
decisions before I do them because
people are watching and people are
following and people are copying and
then being responsible say my personal
brand I have a personal brand people
know that I exist
yeah and the question is what do they
think about me and and how how is my
brand and how am i known for so um yeah
I think it's really important as you say
everyone has a personal brand and if you
had to sum up your personal brand in
three words what would you say is I
would say that it is inspiring mm-hmm I
would say that it is informative and
liberating because I show people that I
show people what can be done so everyone
that says this can't be done this
comment and this can't be done you know
so it's liberating people to freedom to
say actually anyone can do this on a
normal guy here's how I started and then
to even do things like the financial
freedom challenges I do it just to test
myself and push myself but also just to
prove no excuses anyone can do this
that's so cool and is there anyone's
personal brand who you admire I'm not
gonna say inspires because he can't
explain okay go for it I was thinking
about this just yesterday actually
so it's interesting you say I think I
think Richard Branson has got such a
strong personal brand - yeah he's got
his company which is virgin and another
problem with a lot of influences has
have is that I have a business a lot of
influences it's it's like people are
either do business and then miss out
massively on their personal brand yeah
or they have a personal brand and I have
a following and they're pushing it
pushing it but they're just got zero
business behind it they don't monetize
off of it which is also ridiculous yeah
so and also is deserving people because
people want more there's a lot of
influences out there and it's are you
great but how do we actually do business
with you how to meet what is your
product or service and no one knows with
me it's quite clear my property investor
and I'm financially free and I teach
people how to become financially for
and as a result of that I have a
training company and I also have joint
venture students and we do big deals
together so it's just very very clear
you know I have my property investors
crash course on every single YouTube
video that I do I know that if people
want to connect with me a much deeper
level and want to want my brain of
property imprinted on their brain they
need to come to the crash course now
it's free but still this is this these
other next steps this is this is what I
would suggest that you do but some
influencers don't have that it's just
they just rule us and then and then
they'll build it all holier-than-thou
you know oh wow you know I just do this
for the fun of it and blah listen if you
do it for the fun of it and that's the
only reason you're gonna stop doing it
at some point because it will become
unfun yeah it will become unfun you have
days when you'll be like oh man I don't
want to shoot another YouTube video so
unless you have a business behind it
you're just gonna give up at some point
because as soon as it gets on fun you're
gonna think what what's the point and
you'll stop and then you get out of the
habit because if you've got a business
behind it it's fun you did cuz you love
doing it but you're also getting paid to
do it
so make as much money as you possibly
can as an influencer without being
inauthentic or in congruent with your
brand what did you learn from Richard
Branson's personal brand okay the reason
I love Richard Branson's brand so much
is because he okay rich people often
have a bad rep it's like oh they met
lots of money then must have trampled
over the poor and most business people
are successful in business they've got
that certain negative connotation like
Lord Sugar for instance okay he's really
rich he's awesome he's got a strong
personal brand but he is a little bit of
an ass you know he's you know he's rude
to people and that's his brand but
Richard Branson he's kind he's
fun-loving he works hard but he's also
got this massive sense of freedom and
whilst that is very true he's made that
happen and he's embraced that as part of
his personal brand even like his hair
and stuff he's just got this real sense
of freedom around him and although he's
a Multi multi billionaire
one of the one of the richest people in
Britain he's also clearly he's not doing
it for the money he's not driven he's
not driven by the money their money
their money he just does he just come
everything he does is from a position of
abundance and I just I just really
respect I mean I've had the privilege of
meeting him a couple times but I just
really respect him I respect his life
philosophies and stuff and I really
respect his brand how he's built his
personal brand and he's got virgin
business brand ticky and he's kind of
like the spearhead I did you know
Richard Branson's goes I've got a
business partner he's got a proper
full-on business partner but but but but
obviously the business partner has
chosen to let him be the the face of it
yeah the face and the Browns yeah he's
crazy not to know about that like never
looked into it properly but you would
just think you would know that sort of
thing yeah almost like a quiet yeah you
know some people are like that though
some people don't like their so a lot of
people are kind of like even for example
I'm winners on a Wednesday like we tell
people how much winners on a Wednesday
will help them with their brand and so
with that some people just don't see the
opportunity in it somebody we don't want
to come on come so yes so tell me
everything about where and why so many
people firstly tell me how many people
are booked on right now because I know
it's crazy ya know it's insane so we are
pretty fully booked until March at the
minute the way we're doing it is trying
to say for example we've got a lot of
success students and people that are
just finishing the Academy and things
like that and they know that they're
gonna be on Windows on Wednesday but
they just wanna for example they've just
closing some deals they're just they're
just busy in property so I've booked
them in for next year
and I'm gonna be on their back and I'm
gonna be like Karen where you up to when
are we doing when is Wednesday I've put
you in for February he's still gonna be
able to do it then and that kind of
thing but the overall vision and for
winners on a Wednesday is at the minute
we have people come on and more message
people and we're sharing the story but
after that it's kind of like we'll stay
in touch but there's there's no connect
community that the winners go into so
people become a winner yeah they get
branded and
the reasons that we set up winners
Wednesday was because on my youtube
channel on it's very much to my youtube
channel I'm doing deals I'm making money
I'm teaching I'm on every video and we
wanted to I mean the initial idea was
give our students who are making moves
taking action like my philosophy is you
make one move I make ten yeah and you
know this even there's someone that
knows me yeah you know you you you show
commitment you put time aside I'm gonna
watch what happens and and I wanted to
set up a set up whereby when my students
would we're kicking ass and taking names
and making money and going out okay my
YouTube channels a massive asset to me
because it brands me and people see me
if he probably deals with me
so I thought well what I bring on some
of my top students yeah let them have an
opportunity to share their story let
them be the teacher and I'll sit back
and I'll just ask them questions let
them be the expert and at the same time
they'll in brand themself get thousands
and thousands of views dude your
adventures you have to do deals be able
to say you know screw you to all the
school friends and family said he
wouldn't work or whatever their
motivation is it's just a massive
platform for people yeah so that's what
started happening and then he became a
weekly thing every Wednesday and but
then when you came on you'e like this
could be so much better yeah because
they're coming on and they're being
branded but then all these winners need
to be continually like you've reminded
that how awesome they are opportunities
to come back on the show yeah also you
wanted to set up a community with them
so now what have you done what have you
done to set up a community with the
winners so I've probably been looking at
stuff for like the past three weeks
maybe yeah and yeah one of the things
that you've just mentioned is and we're
trying to have people on more than once
so we want to kind of motivate people to
because I think sometimes people like
with anything and at the beginning
you're super motivated and then it kind
of slowly drifts off and we want people
to stay motivated and we want people to
yeah just keep going keep being
successful you know when you like
astronauts don't fly to the moon I don't
if you knew this but when they get back
often really depressed
there's no way out there's no way higher
and bigger yeah and and you saw that
with sometimes people I I want to get on
Windows Wednesday I want to become
financially free and I want to get on
Windows Wednesday quit the job that
become financially free the government
is Wednesday and then to be a big fat
tick and and then and then they just
take over yeah when you approach to all
the winners and you were like since
we're not win as well as they're six
months ago what you've done and then
I'll actually I've not really been
pushing so hard man I've left in a
couple deals and then and now you're
saying now we want an ultimate financial
freedom where you're you ten times what
you did and then we'll get you back on
the channel again for a part two we'll
do a documentary on you if needs be
we'll get you back on yeah and it just
creates like a new level of for people
yeah because I think sometimes as well
like people are that kind of like tick
yeah that's like ticket they've done it
and then that's that was you you want to
be continually pushing yeah I feel like
sometimes people kind of like just want
to tick things off their list so I'll be
like okay Academy okay now and when it's
on Wednesday and I just feel like this
we don't want there to be this kind of
tick box okay that's it I've done some
you loose train and have you know that's
it I've completed it I'm financially
free now that's it that's it no we want
people to aim higher we want people to
build their brands I think on our when
is our Wednesday the one I've got the
most I'm sure it's like over 60 K yeah
yeah yeah and it's just incredible and
those people that have been on one of
the Wednesday they'll go on about how
many messages they get and how much
people will be like oh well how did you
find it how did you do it and they'll
often like the success students come
with us to crash courses and things like
that and but yeah I'm basically just
trying to make it a bit more of a
community
Seren dinners yeah so we're doing dinner
so we're actually booking that in today
I was negotiating with the event the
other day there's nothing that I love
more Emilia than having a big dinner
with people who are all financially free
especially as a resort of my training
I'm sat there having dinner with like 30
40 people and every single one of them
full-time in property they've all quit
their jobs are financially free they're
making a fortune in property but two
years ago they didn't that there were no
teachers or they were working as a
builder or they're working as a
solicitor and I'm just like wow yeah
and it's just something how often were
gonna run their dinners so I think we're
gonna do them we're gonna start every
six months I love doing them quarterly
she's good
yeah I just think it's just such a
missed opportunity to make the winners
like come together because obviously
when you know you're at this dinner this
like dinner networking event you know
that everyone is super serious so it's
like when someone says oh yeah I'm gonna
do it or oh yeah I do this I think this
you know that you know there's Samuel
leed-certified like you know that
doesn't rain in the made the money yeah
so it's even like for example if you
were like taking a step back and you
wanted a deal saw so if you mess when it
they're winners on Wednesday dinner you
would know okay
this person has been through the
training I've been through I can trust
them that kind of thing
so yeah I'm super excited were booking
in the one for January and what else
yeah it's just gonna be more of a
community you've got the Facebook group
now people to conversate and we're
getting people in the newspapers all the
time oh yeah do you know there's been 32
students over the last 18 months success
teams though I've been the newspapers
[Music]
that's their stories so amazing that the
and I'm talking big newspapers often
things like Daily Mail the Sun big
papers you don't even know this people
don't know and so I just wanna I want to
lay out all the positives coming on when
is it Wednesday because sometimes people
be like oh like I saying before that I
don't want to be on camera I don't want
to do this and I'm like you're missing
such a big opportunity windows Wednesday
sometimes people's favorite day every
Wednesday yeah because the motivation
because the thing is if I'm talking
about what I did hey I did this and I've
done this and here's how I did it and is
some people might be like that's great
for you or they might not relate to me
totally but then when I'm saying hey
here's this 20 year old hey here's this
70 year old woman hey here's this person
who can hardly speak English
and then they share their story it just
adds a real sense of my goodness
I can relate to that or you know if they
can do it sure so I just I think it's
great I love windows Wednesday I love
what we're doing with that it's all in
it so it is all about relatability like
even I was saying to you and so me my
mom came to York radical yeah and the
reason other than yourself
we came along is because we saw Leah and
Cheryl's story and I could
really relate to that is a mother and
daughter relationship yeah so yeah we
often get people coming on and even when
we do the winners now your last them
okay who inspired you yeah from the last
winners and then we can point out their
video what do you want for the winners
to make it more of a community I just I
just well I just want people that have
been financially free through the
training I want them to just continue
wanting to do more and more so rather
than just thinking and that's not how I
live my life like when I became
financially free I'm straightaway
thinking okay what next
okay I'll make some more money and what
next okay I can sell this charity okay
what next oh one day Terry yeah I was
with you I've even logged a little bit
there did way yeah we found out what we
were just we're in the middle of a crash
course yeah and you got phone call yeah
they said charities registered finally
yes so excited its people that said oh
we did yet what's going on we charge he
wasn't no we just did I'm like have
yourself a charity clearly you haven't
because it's not like setting up a
limited company it is a pain so uh how's
dad and the reason it took me so long
was because for ages I didn't even want
to charity because I've just number one
I didn't want to ask people from an edge
swings use my own money and I think
secondly is I just wanted to I just
wanted to be known for doing business
and making money I just didn't want to I
don't know I just didn't want to push
like oh by the way we're doing this in
Africa and this the other I just I've
been doing it for years I've been going
out to my freaking and digging wells and
doing business workshops literally
you've been to nine different nine
different African country way before I
was financially for even I mean when I
went to Africa when I was 18 I spent a
month in Zambia that was what really
incentivize me do you think man if I've
got the ability the god-given brain to
to go and make money and I mean the
country to do that but I'm not going to
do because of apathy or laziness or fear
when I could actually inspire and then
physically help a lot of people that be
wrong so that was something did a few
years and years so so I delayed it a
little bit for that reason because
there's no point having a charity if I'm
not asking for donations but then from
tax reasons
made sense also people wanted to give so
for the last year or so we've been
working on it and finally got the charge
number last week so pumped is there
anything you can share about your plans
with the charity yeah I mean I'm stuff
so I'm taking you out next year yes I'm
so excited and I take a lot of people
out you know again people that are on
Windows Wednesday or whoever people that
have become financially free from the
Train I want to take them out
so the moment we're building a school in
Uganda I'm also try mall so I've been
working with the Ugandan government I've
been talking to all the different
schools and the officials I'm trying I'm
trying to change the way that the
education system is taught around
I think they should teach kids about
money that's it I think the kids should
be taught around money finance business
development because ultimately I think
that's the that is the that is the key
to relieve poverty and you know the same
teach a man to fish he'll eat for a
lifetime if you just give a man a fish
he'll eat for a day I think that whilst
in Africa we do do a lot of giving fish
and some of it's very sustained of all
that whales and water and also just food
clothes
I just think education running a
business is and we've seen it happen
with the business workshops and stuff
that we've been teaching and the free
business loans I think that is
ultimately what's going to bring
sustainability change so now man I'm
really excited I love going out there I
love the sunshine I love the culture I'm
married to it to a Zimbabwean Africa my
day so it's brilliant I'm just so glad
that we have finally had the charity
number no that's so exciting in terms of
your plans for 2020 with the business
yeah in terms of the property business
what are you doing with that tell me a
bit about that what are some of the
investment side yes okay so as you
normally do a review don't you every
year you do a review on YouTube of what
you've done for the previous year and
what you're doing going forward yeah I
want to say that for YouTube mm-hmm I
want to say that for you chief oh I
don't know this is this is all soap
opera YouTube I've been in a whole
YouTube video about that okay I guess
the question why I do that is because
most rich people hide so they don't want
people to know what they're doing
hold their cards close to their chest
and I just don't wanna live like that I
just want everyone to see what I'm doing
I wanna be open about it
MacDonald published their business plan
publicly because they're so enthroned
because they're so big and I just I just
need that way of thinking which is
here's what I'm doing guys
do you know what really poor people do
really broke people do is the thing I'm
not gonna tell you what about the idea
because then everyone will copy me
no one's gonna copy you dick no wants to
do no one wants to copy you
I mean come on yeah so scared about
copying ya over yourself
no one wants to copy you and if they do
copy you and they become successful then
good on them yeah no I'm just so not
interested in trying to call back what
I'm doing and I remember when I was when
I was starting out in property and I'd
see people that were really successful I
try and pick their brain over a coffee
whatever I'll be an event buying on and
it would all be to boom and close to
their chest and I'd have these riddles
spoken so I couldn't understand it or
figure out why what's the threat what's
the problem
so I just want to tell people what I'm
doing if people copy me then good on
them you know why because it takes a lot
of commitment to succeed I can give you
the exact blueprint of how to do bum bum
bum bum bum bum yeah but takes a lot of
commitment to come at this happen good
luck yeah even if for example before you
became a thing if you gave the business
plan of Eber to you know a hundred
different people like if some of them
wouldn't even be able to make it work
because it's like they wouldn't have to
commitment they weren't up the drive
wouldn't know how to get funded but
there's so much that goes into making
someone a business there's a million
good ideas yeah there's a million good
ideas but there's a few good people that
will go and make it happen
yeah it's more about the person like
when we were talking to James Caan he
was saying that he invest in people
wasn't he rather than like their
business yeah it's kind of guess with
the apprentice as well and Load trigger
like he always looks at the person how
they've done over the weeks rather than
realistically like their business plan
he doesn't even like it if they've been
that successful yeah because he likes to
find people that have got potential see
that in the person then bring that out
and James can 100% so that's why I'm
publishing it so that will happen
probably probably towards the end of
this month
we're filming it this week this week so
this week we're gonna be filming number
one a video
exactly what I've bought in 2009/10 and
then number two what my plans are to buy
in 2020 all I say is 2020 is gonna be
big we're working on some big deals I've
got my brother-in-law ban then my
checking younger and he's he's now
full-time in the property business so
he's left his job he used to be a wait
he's a chartered surveyor he's left that
to come and work on the business on that
property business full-time so yeah big
big plans amazing thank you for letting
me interview and ask you a few questions
about personal branding and everything
that you've been up to this week and
we'll see you next week it's been great
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]